Germany's players and supporters could barely tear themselves away from the Maracana...
...as Brazil's World Cup got the winners it deserved and the winning goal it deserved.
It was a joyous scene and one in which no luck was involved.
This was a World Cup victory, their fourth...
...by German design and years in the making...
...the 1-0 final win over Argentina was merely confirmation of the success of a strategy...
...forged on embarrassments at successive Euros in 2000 and 2004.
When Mario Gotze took Andre Schurrle's pass on his chest...
...with only seven minutes of extra time left...
...and volleyed his finish past Argentine keeper Sergio Romero,...
...it was not simply a German win for now,...
...it could be one that sets the platform for years of success.